you were talking about dating profiles
do you have like you've done a lot of
research in this area about what to do
so do you know where men go wrong with
dating profiles and what they should do
is it like photos they all they're all
they all have fish or something
there's a lot of fish on tinder i know
it's uh okay so so a couple thoughts so
you mentioned before the the the study
that i had cited about how
um
so men tend to swipe right they tend to
like the profiles of
more than 60 percent of the women that
they encounter
whereas um
women only swipe right on uh 4.5 right
so very you know as a guy you know it's
very very slim slim odds so
where they go wrong the fish picture is
interesting i talked to uh one of the
the former uh product guys at tinder
and
he told me that actually fish pro fish
pictures
tend to tend to actually do pretty well
welcome to episode 143 of the michaela
peterson podcast i'm michaela peterson i
have a very fun podcast for you good
folks today my guest rob henderson is a
doctoral candidate at cambridge
university
rob henderson grew up in foster homes in
california he joined the air force at
the age of 17. after serving he attended
yale on the gi bill and was subsequently
awarded a gates cambridge scholarship to
study at the university of cambridge
he's written for the new york times the
wall street journal and colette among
other outlets and coined the phrase
luxury beliefs for the beliefs held by
rich people basically rob's great we
covered the dark triad of personality
psychopathy narcissism and
machiavellianism
people encompassing dark triad traits
are skilled at manipulation and making
you fall in love with them particularly
if you're female
we discussed his concept of luxury
beliefs sexual attraction dating apps in
the time of covid wokism and woke
fishing which is hilarious the rise in
self-censoring writing and more please
be sure to subscribe if you enjoy this
episode or this type of content this
episode was brought to you by nordvpn
nordvpn is the fastest vpn in the entire
world
also super legit for sponsoring me you
may not know all the ways nordvpn can
protect you phishing sites for example
can look just like the real thing one
careless click and poof your dad is gone
hackers can then ask for ransom and even
then you're not guaranteed to ever see
it again
seemingly normal websites can also
infect your devices with malware
unless you use nordvpn nordvpn is
undoubtedly the best in the game take it
from someone who's been using vpns for
years to avoid canadian netflix
it works across all your devices as well
take advantage of my exclusive offer
today and see what full online
protection really feels like grab your
nordvpn deal today over at nordvpn.com
tmpp or use promo code tmpp for a huge
discount off their premium plans an
extra free month and a secret bonus gift
all with nordvpn's 30 day money back
guarantee again that's only at
nordvpn.com
tmpp
or promo code tmpp the acronym for this
podcast
thanks for watching this episode
[Music]
rob henderson welcome to my podcast hi
michaela thanks it's great to be here
this is gonna be a fun conversation
we're going to go through a bunch of
your articles sure have a lot of
questions uh but before we get started
can you give a brief background about
who you are and what it is you do
uh yeah sure i am a phd candidate at the
university of cambridge they study
social and evolutionary psychology
i've published in peer-reviewed articles
but i'm probably most well-known for my
popular writing so i've written in
colette the new york times the wall
street journal among other outlets and
i'm really interested in things like
social status social class
personality the dark triad which we
might get into later
and yeah sort of cultural and social
commentary
okay i think we should actually just
start right off with the dark triad
because that's really interesting so can
we start by just can you give an
explanation about what that means
yeah so the dark triad is a personality
constellation that encompasses three
different traits
so the three traits are narcissism
psychopathy and machiavellianism
uh narcissism is essentially entitled
self-importance uh narcissism itself is
is fairly complex and we can get into
the sort of nuances there but it is sort
of you know most people are familiar
with what narcissism is
psychopathy is
callousness cynicism a sort of disregard
for other people
and machiavellianism is uh
sort of a duplicity
and
the willingness to sort of exploit
others for personal gain a sort of cold
calculated mindset
and together these three personality
traits tend to go together in the same
person they all sort of correlate so if
one person scores high in narcissism
they tend to score fairly high in
psychopathy and machiavellianism as well
but there is some variation you might be
high in one and maybe not so high on the
other but they tend to tend to go
together
how much of those just correspond to
being disagreeable in the big five
they're extremely highly correlated with
the the disagreeable uh with the
disagreeability in the big five
personality traits so
there's been uh multiple studies on this
uh on which of the big five correlate
with the dark triad
and of the big five agreeableness is the
most correlated meaning negatively
correlated so the higher
you are on agreeability the lower you
tend to score on the dark triad
but there's some
variation too with the others so if
you're high on the dark triad you tend
to score a little bit higher on for
example extroversion
if you score high on psychopathy they
tend to score a little bit high on
openness but the correlations are much
weaker it's really about
agreeableness if you're a dark triad
person you tend to be uh extremely
disagreeable person
you said if you score higher on
psychopathy then you tend to score a bit
higher on openness but it's a weak
correlation yeah it's a weak correlation
that's interesting yeah okay
so
one of your articles
okay so you wrote about the dark triad
in psychology today and in quillette
and i believe it was psychology today oh
yeah dark personalities are more likely
to signal victimhood
so
so that surprises me a bit because i
always thought that it was more
agreeable people that tended towards
being victims but that's not what this
suggests
well it's it's a little bit tricky so
the that paper it was a fascinating
paper i think was published in 2020 uh
the journal of personality and social
psychology
uh
you know a series of very interesting
studies
and they weren't claiming so the
researchers were not claiming based on
the studies that they ran that
uh actual victims score higher on dark
triad personality traits what they were
claiming is that people who tend to
score high on dark triad personality
traits tend to signal victimhood more
and signaling victimhood is not
necessarily the same thing as actually
being a victim right and so people who
are truly
um
sort of the the targets of misfortune or
suffering have really gone through bad
things those aren't the people who you
know tend to be narcissists or
psychopaths but the people tend to be
narcissists and psychopaths uh will sort
of exploit people's empathy and sort of
exploit people's willingness to help
suffering people uh by by playing a
victim
and so you know of course they ran the
the standard um dark triad scales sort
of asking people there there's questions
about how they um interact with other
people and how they move through the
world whether they tend to be cold and
calculating and so forth whether they're
sort of believe themselves to be more
important than other people but then
they also created a victim a victim
signaling scale
and it included items like you know i
tend to uh
want to broadcast that people like me
are are sort of not as well known as we
should be or how you know more people
who are like me need to be
represented in the media or or um
in
sort of though the public conversation
basically like you know they're they're
they're put upon they're sort of
suffering in some way
and
they tend to highly correlate so the
higher you are in dark triad the more
signaling you do in terms of victimhood
signaling so
they also found some interesting it
wasn't just correlational studies so
they weren't just administering scales
and finding that they tended to
correlate they were also doing
experimental studies as well
basically in one of the studies what
they did was uh the the psychologists
rigged a game in which participants
could uh win some money but what the
psychologist did was um rigged it so
that it was really easy to cheat and it
was really easy for them to figure out
who cheated
and first they had people play this game
they tracked who cheated in the game to
win more money
um and they also had these participants
take the um the dark triad personality
scale and they found that the people who
scored highly on the scale also were
more likely to cheat to win more money
at this game
they also did these interesting studies
where they um
basically imagine the participants to
envision themselves in um
in a sort of an employment scenario so
they have a colleague at work
who and and they're described as being a
little bit unpleasant to be around and
maybe they don't like them very much and
so on so this is the person they're
imagining but then the researchers asked
the participants um
you know uh how much do you agree with
these with these items these statements
like you know this colleague insults you
all the time uh this colleague has taken
advantage of you and all of these things
the this this colleague has done bad
things to you his colleague needs to be
fired nothing in the description of this
person in this sort of scenario
indicated that they had ever insulted
the participant that they had ever um
done anything wrong to them but they
basically the scenario was like this
person just don't like them very much
right
um and again the researchers found that
people who score high on dark trad are
more likely to exaggerate or
fabricate negative qualities about this
other person
uh and say how bad badly they've been
treated by them
huh i wonder if they actually believe
that or not has there been any like is
it full-on lying is it is it to get
somewhere or do they switch that in
their head so they think that they've
been insulted
yeah i don't even know if uh
like it's an interesting question
but
you know i'm not i may not matter
because the outcome is such that this is
how they behave
and you know the the researchers uh in
that paper you know they document how
you know findings from from insurance
fraud claims right like you know some
some x number of millions or billions of
dollars every year um are lost because
of people who are fraudulently filing
insurance claim you know people who
claim that they can't seek employment
and so basically a lot of people will
sort of exploit weaknesses and various
systems in order to extract economic
gain or whatever kind of gain happens to
be
but you know people who score highly on
the dark triad they are they tend to be
more preoccupied with with status with
sexual rewards so material rewards
social rewards sexual rewards
and
whatever environment they happen to find
themselves in
they will
enact the strategies to extract those
rewards so if they happen to be say in
you know the modern west in the year
2022 they might find that oh the best
strategy to extract rewards is to signal
victimhood and so that's what they'll do
to sort of uh exploit the weaknesses in
the system but if they're somewhere else
you know maybe being an extreme
narcissist might be the best way to do
it so they'll sort of lean into that and
that's the best way to to get attention
to get
romantic partners or whatever it happens
to be so they tend to be very good um at
sort of
picking up on you know what are the
what are the ways uh to maximize those
rewards in whatever social environment
they happen to be in
okay so
that's very interesting but
that type of person sounds like an
unattractive type of person right anyone
who's signaling victimhood without
actually being a victim i don't think
anyone finds that attractive
however
according to
what like what you wrote
women are more attracted to people who
score higher in these dark triad
personality traits
yeah well
that was a study um i want to see it's
from 2015 uh his team of researchers um
they had some women evaluate uh a man uh
basically his suitability as a romantic
partner
and what they found is that men who
score highly on the dark triad relative
to an ordinary man so an average guy
versus a guy who's really high on the
dark triad they score the the dark triad
guy um to be quite a bit more attractive
so one standard deviation more
attractive than the average and a
standard deviation is is a lot in in
psychological research that sort of uh
that gap
um
i'd imagine i can't remember the
specific details of how they sort of
characterized this guy this dark triad
guy but i'd imagine they weren't saying
like he you know talks about how he's a
victim or whatever yeah um they probably
talk about how he tends to be um sort of
superficially charming and maybe a
little bit callous and uncaring and
emotionally distant and these kinds of
things and something else i i had
written in that in that article sort of
summarizing a lot of this research um
justin lay miller who's a a sexual
psychologist wrote a book called tell me
what you want about sexual fantasies
and he writes about how
uh the most fantasized about superheroes
among women
uh the most fantasized superhero is
batman
which is a an interesting contrast with
the most fantasized superhero among gay
men which which are uh captain america
and superman and i found that kind of
that that uh that difference to be
interesting right because like superman
and captain america are like these uh
goody two-shoes boy scouts like you know
these are the the guys that little boys
look up to as like the
the sort of like the the
the the most pure and noble superheroes
and i think batman is often seen as like
the sort of darker edgier
you know like almost like he's a villain
but he still does the right thing but
you could imagine him going to the dark
side and this is the guy that that women
you know of all the superheroes that's
the one that they seem to like the most
that's so funny
that's so funny i never liked captain
america just like that what about
superman boring uh superman too well
superman mostly because it's like he he
can do everything
so he's just he's gonna win
right he's like okay
too old of a superhero there's no
weakness there what's his we i guess
kryptonite's the weakness but i mean
come on
one thing i would be curious about i
don't have any research on this but um i
don't know did you see that new james
bond movie no time to die
is that the newest one the newest one
within the cake yeah it came out like a
couple months ago
okay no i haven't i really want to see
that have you seen it yeah yeah i
thought it was good it's not like the
best james bond ever but i i thought it
was really really good um but one of the
things that's interesting about the the
bond series is how like the sort of the
earlier bond movies were sort of more
campy a little bit there was a little
bit more humor in them but starting with
the latest bond with daniel craig
uh like the series took this more sort
of darker edgier turn and the daniel
craig bond um he he gets injured more
he's more vulnerable he gets beaten up
um you can sort of see the physical
effects throughout the movie of him sort
of becoming more and more damaged and he
himself is sort of a more edgy and rough
character and i would love to see you
know if there's any data on like maybe
30 years ago whoever was born 30 years
ago how did women feel about that bond
versus the bond today and see like if
which james bond is like the most
appealing to to women or to viewers in
general
yeah or if that
has changed right i mean maybe it was
the same percentage of women back then
as it is now but women now don't find
that attractive oh that's a good point
too yep yep
that's interesting this episode was
brought to you by rabbit air i used to
have real trouble getting quality sleep
but had no idea why after ruling out a
bunch of things like stress it turned
out i was allergic to dust in my room so
i got an air purifier and my sleep got
better overnight that was years ago now
it's allergy season and i'm so allergic
to nashville i can't be here it's crazy
it's an allergy soup bowl and rabbit air
is making it more tolerable
plus look they put a lion on it which is
so cute there it is
so cute
so cute
i'm very picky about what air purifiers
i use they need to be hepa and they need
to be good because i'm basically a
bubble person i'm not entirely sure why
i even survived this long to be
to be truthful to you guys but rabbit
air has super clean quiet and very slick
looking air purifiers that i can't
recommend enough rabider's award-winning
purifiers use advanced filtration
technology to target airborne allergens
particles and even annoying smells that
are hard to get rid of
do yourself a favor and visit
rabbitair.com today they have a
five-year warranty free shipping and
returns and a 90-day money-back
guarantee on all their products that's
r-a-b-b-i-t-a-i-r-dot-com
for some of the best air purifiers
you'll find out there no matter where
you look and you can make them look
super cute you can even you can even
copy mine if you really want to but
i don't know if anybody wants to do that
but anyway
thank you to them for saving my lungs
i want to read it there so there were a
couple parts of one of these papers that
i thought were
really interesting so i'll just read a
few of them
we can we can talk about that
um
okay
ooh this was dark this was dark and i
didn't know that i didn't actually know
this so the book you're talking about
david buss's book right
right when men behave badly which is a
great book yep yeah i need to talk to
him that would be really fun okay so the
book reports chilling research about
predatory males researchers videotaped
individuals walking down the same block
in new york city the tapes were shown to
53 prison inmates convicted of violent
crimes inmates showed a strong consensus
on who they would victimize they chose
individuals who moved in an
uncoordinated manner with a stride that
was too short or too long for their
height in another set of studies
researchers found an association between
men's chosen targets and women's
self-reported frequency of having been
sexually victimized in the past
this suggests that women suffering from
unwanted sexual encounters inadvertently
emit cues that predatory males could
detect
right yeah yeah that was i thought it
was a very
dark excerpt in that book too
and and it shocked me um
because i had already known just you
know just from reading a lot of the the
psychological research on dark triad
that again they tend to sort of pick up
on the cues and the signals for them to
obtain what they want
but yeah i would have never imagined
that they could actually like sort of
survey you know
a bunch of pedestrians walking and say
like oh there's the vulnerable one and
it's almost like you know what makes me
think of is like you know when you see
like national geographic or whatever
animal documentaries and you see like
the lion looking for like the the
gazelle that's like limping you know the
one that looks a little bit slower
smaller more vulnerable than the others
and they're sort of like surveying which
one of these should i go after and that
was sort of what it made me think here
and you know i think there's there's
probably some
you know i think i think it's a useful
way to think about it i've seen for
example
research papers on psychopathy who
describe um
the the gays like the the way that
psychopaths look at other people um
they've described as reptilian you know
there's this sort of like animalistic
um
quality to it that when people make eye
contact for a long period of time with
with people who are emotionally vacant
and who only see you for what you can
provide to them or what they can extract
from you um
apparently a lot of clinicians and
researchers describe this as a very sort
of chilling experience like wow that
you're looking to the eyes
someone who cares who doesn't see you as
a human being
interesting
do you think there's
any use for this information so for more
like for lack of a better term for more
agreeable men
more agreeable men i assume are going to
have a harder time attracting women
because women are more attracted to
these dark triad traits is there a way
for people to kind of present themselves
in a manner that
embodies these traits without actually
being
a terrible person
you know it's funny i have a a good
friend of mine here at cambridge um he's
a criminologist vincent harinam he has
coined this idea of the dark
i think he calls it the dark gentleman
uh and i may be getting some of the
details wrong but it's essentially the
sort of this marriage between
a guy who's maybe a little bit edgy and
you know
ambitious and
it can be maybe somewhat emotionally
distant but they know what they want
they're sort of using
um
you know using some of those those
qualities to pursue what they want while
also sort of having a soft side to them
you know the sort of uh
whatever like the dad versus the cad but
sort of those two things put together
um i suppose yeah i mean people can
cultivate and
and suppress various aspects of their
nature i mean broadly speaking in the
personality research our personalities
like the big five they tend to be pretty
stable throughout our lives you know if
you measure at age 18 compared to
you know fifteen year fifties or
something the correlation tends to be
around point eight i mean it's very
stable
but that's sort of um
looking in the aggregate scale you know
across multiple many individuals across
time but as an individual person
you can sort of and i'm sure people have
experienced this where
um you may want to say be more
extroverted you know in a social
situation maybe you're more of an
introvert maybe you're more of a bookish
type uh but you want to make friends or
you want to
get promoted or something so you sort of
become more extroverted or pretend to be
that way and i think guys can do this
too with
with uh maybe being slightly more
disagreeable while you know retaining
some of the
the the good guy traits um speaking of
extroversion
um this reminds me of some interesting
research on this too that
generally speaking people are
they report being happier when they
behave in a more extroverted way
and this is not just true for people who
score high on extroversion but
introverts too
if you uh tell introverts you know if
introverts are in a study and the
researchers say like you know go go
behave in a more social way interact
with more people talk to more people
today
um introduce yourself to more people
than you normally would something like
that
they actually report being happier
than when they behave in an introverted
way when they sort of go against their
impulses you know maybe they want to
stay inside but they force themselves to
go out and i find this interesting too
that sometimes you know going against
your own personality uh impulses can can
actually increase your sense of
well-being
that's interesting i have a theory that
okay so you know if you
if you're an extremely agreeable person
you you tend to value you tend to
you can potentially kind of cram down
whatever you're feeling
so that you don't hurt anybody's
feelings right oh i don't want to say
that because this person might interpret
it this way and if they feel sad i'm
going to feel sad because i'm an
agreeable person
i think that if people learn how to
overcome that and actually say how they
feel they feel better i think it might
just be harder for agreeable people
because they care more about other
people's feelings but that kind of thing
i think you can practice and you're like
okay you're concerned you're gonna say
something it's gonna hurt somebody's
feelings
but you should probably say it you have
that feeling in you if you just do that
and then you survey the outcome and
you're like okay this wasn't as bad as i
thought it was gonna be i think if you
practice that you can get over that and
i think
for men who are more prone to
being agreeable like that i think that's
probably a good thing to practice in
general but also to make you more
attracted to women
yeah yeah yeah i think there's there's
uh
i mean that's definitely i think a
useful way to do it and
and also i mean beyond
you know trying to
whatever like shape your personality in
different ways or behave differently you
can also just sort of put yourself in
places where people might be more
attracted to a more agreeable man
so if you you know
maybe maybe going out to uh i don't know
a nightclub or something is not the
ideal place if you're more of say an
agreeable or introverted kind of guy but
i don't know religious services or or
libraries or something like maybe
they're more you know women there might
be more more interested in a more
agreeable kind of person so definitely
you can sort of put yourself in the
right environment as well
um but yeah i mean i think the dating
question is fascinating just because i
know
i think it's just it's just becoming
more difficult for a lot of young people
i know guys who are you know they have
good careers they have good income all
those kinds of things and
they
have some of them had to make it a
second job basically of like
reorganizing their lives in order to
find a suitable romantic partner i think
it's getting pretty pretty rough out
there
so what does that mean reorganizing
their lives
yeah so like a friend of mine for
example he
uh
you know sort of changed the hours he
worked at in order to go to cooking
classes because he just figured you know
he likes to cook and he wants to meet
you know a person who would want to cook
too
you know
sort of going to the gym at the right
hours
just sort of generally changing his
habits and introducing himself to more
people um getting his uh dating apps
like
he had like a lot of input from
different women and different people who
could help him like portray you know
convey himself in in the way that that
would maximize his chances of finding a
suitable
uh partner
and i think a lot of guys you know
they're they don't do this you know they
just sort of go through life and wonder
what's going on
and other guys are realizing like oh it
really is something you have to take
seriously it's not something that's just
going to happen by accident for you you
and i'm sure women are having in many
ways the same kind of experience but you
know just speaking from you know most of
my friends said to be guys and this is
sort of their experience and
yeah it really is um
you know they're spending hours a week
on on this on this project of how to
find a how to find a
girlfriend yeah okay well we could talk
about that but but first okay so this
kind of has to do with what you just
said um
this is from your article as well
because of the increased risk women
carry they tend to be choosier about
their partners
in contrast men are less discerning
studies of online dating for example
find that most men find most women to be
at least somewhat attractive in contrast
women on average view 80 of men as below
average in attractiveness another study
found that on the dating app tinder men
liked more than 60 percent of the female
profiles they viewed while women liked
only four and a half percent of male
profiles so this might be a problem
that's
way more prevalent for men i didn't
realize that 80 percent of men is below
average
that's quite off
it is i mean right because you know you
would think like 50 right it's sort of
like 50 above and 50 below but to have
80 percent
rated below is pretty you know it's
pretty grim um
but this this sort of reflects our
uh innate evolutionary psychology you
know so a lot of evolutionary
researchers
uh essentially find that you know
because men carry less risk for uh well
during sex right they're less likely
even if they have sex with someone uh
they're less likely to contract uh an
std
than women are
i don't know and yeah yeah and so well i
mean because men's like organs are on
the outside whereas women's are on the
inside and that sort of affects you know
uh likely to contracting but then also
of course pregnancy itself
um is extremely burdensome and you can
imagine you know it's already burdensome
in the modern era but you can imagine um
you know 50 or 100 000 years ago in the
ancestral environment where humans
evolved you know like getting pregnant
for a woman was uh it was a
life-or-death uh experience in many many
cases so
um as a result of this women have
evolved to be much more selective about
who they have sex with um you know they
want a guy who sort of has you know good
good genetic quality but also a guy who
sort of
uh could take care of them and provide
for them and all those things whereas
for men the risk was so minuscule and
the potential gain of having a kid was
so high in evolutionary terms right in
terms of having more kids and so
um for this reason i i once had this
this line i i said this on our mutual
friend chris williamson's podcast um
yeah a couple years ago now which is
basically that for men the default when
they evaluate women the default is i
would probably sleep with her
unless there's some
extraordinary reason why i shouldn't
and for women the default is i
definitely wouldn't sleep with him
unless there's some extraordinary reason
why i should
so we sort of start from different
positions it's it's not exactly accurate
but i think it gets at this intuition
that guys are just less picky at least
when it comes to sex with relationships
it's a little different but for women um
much more selective again because of
because of that risk of pregnancy and so
on that they they tend to carry
that makes sense
okay yeah i like that that's good that's
that's a good line uh
okay so
you were talking about dating profiles
do you have like you've done a lot of
research in this area about what to do
so do you know where men go wrong with
dating profiles and what they should do
is it like photos they all they're all
they all have fish or something
there's a lot of fish on tinder i know
it's uh okay so so a couple thoughts so
so you mentioned before the the the
study that i had cited about how
um
so men tend to swipe right they tend to
like the profiles of
more than 60 percent of the women that
they encounter whereas um
women only swipe right on 4.5 right so
very you know as a guy you know it's
very very slim slim odds so
where they go wrong the fish picture is
interesting i talked to uh one of the
the former uh product guys at tinder
and
he told me that actually fish pro fish
pictures
tend to tend to actually do pretty well
uh surprisingly well and he thought it
was we both thought it was funny because
we're you know we're both aware that
there's this sort of trope that people
like fun of it like oh the guy with the
fish but apparently
yeah well you know and i make fun of it
too but i mean apparently if you have a
fish uh picture it does slightly
increase the chances for a guy you know
i don't know about how much but it's
it's better than average
um
other things that guys can do
uh
so so this is really interesting is
having a dog this is something that i
think we all know
um but it's actually a huge benefit
uh to have a dog uh in your in your
dating app picture
uh some i think something like um
you're twice as likely or it might have
been like 60 percent as likely
to to be liked if you have a dog picture
if you have a cat picture
um you're actually less likely to be
liked by a woman if you're a straight
guy so if you're a straight guy looking
for a female partner having a cat is
detrimental so don't have a cat
apparently for gay men it's a little
different i think gay men actually
there's a they have a slight um
uh preference i think for guys who have
cats um but if you're straight guy uh
yeah don't uh don't put a cat get get
the dog um
one other thing uh that guys could do
and this is a little bit more uh
involved in burdensome than just you
know going out and asking your friend to
borrow his dog for a picture
is um
uh continue education
uh so there's research showing that uh
what basically what these these guys did
uh these these scholars did what they
they took um
a picture of the same guy same profile
and the only thing that changed was
whether he had a bachelor's degree or a
master's degree and the guy with a
master's degree got twice as many likes
as the guy with the
bachelor's degree
um and so yeah if you're
on the dating apps and you are you know
sort of serious about finding someone
then maybe uh getting a master's degree
would be it would be wise i think a lot
of people are going to listen to this
and say i'll just put master's degree on
there but you know she'd really should
really get the master's degree
and it helps for women too surprisingly
i think a lot of people are uncertain
about the benefits of education for
women's romantic prospects but actually
women who get master's degrees they did
the same study in the same set of
researchers and found that women with a
master's degree get around i think 10
more likes than women with a bachelor's
degree so it's a slight advantage i
don't know if it's it's enough if you
know it justifies you know getting the
master's degree for 10 more likes
um but it is a slight uh a slight
advantage for them
and and then yeah just generally i've
i've seen other um this isn't research
but this is just like opinions i've seen
from women
uh that you know sort of the bathroom
selfie is is terrible get like good
pictures and those kinds of things
i've i've found so so there's some
conflicting research here on
on um social proof
uh which which david buss has has uh
researched another thing so social proof
is basically um
a lot of research finds that if a guy is
in a picture
with with women
uh women who are observing the picture
rate him as more attractive than when
he's alone or with uh surrounded by guys
um and the idea here is that like oh
well if these women especially if these
are attractive women are willing to you
know be around this guy and tolerate
this guy then you know there's probably
something interesting about him or
something appealing about him so they'll
rate him as more attractive
um but then when it comes to dating uh
apps
guys who post pictures of themselves on
their apps surrounded by women
they tend to get fewer likes than when
they're alone or they're when they're
with guy friends
i'm not exactly sure what's going on
here i think one reason for this might
be that like
you know
women
women may not necessarily be super
interested like i think the picture may
convey that like this guy is unserious
or that he just wants to like have you
know short-term relationships one-night
stands he just wants to have flings and
that's why he has these pictures all
these women he's just
you know i think it gives me the wrong
the wrong vibe but this is you know i i
don't actually know it's just
speculation like why do you think this
would be
yeah well probably i mean if i looked at
that i'd
i think especially if the women were
attractive i think okay that's
potentially
competition and if you're on a dating
app already you're like i just won't
even
won't even get into that i think it's
probably that is like maybe that's
competition and or if you want to think
deeper about it well why is he showing
other women on his dating profile right
but i'd say competition probably if it's
attractive women
yeah yeah that makes sense i mean
yeah yeah so that mismatch was was
intriguing to me i mean
in real life there's other research
showing
you know what guys can do to uh to
maximize their attractiveness or to
increase you know their their appeal
there was a research for example showing
that a guy who carries around um so they
basically had the gu the same guy
he would approach women carrying a
guitar case you know this case in the
shape of a guitar and he would ask women
you know he'd sort of start a short
conversation and then ask for their
number
um
and he you know he approached some
number of women doing it with the guitar
case and then um he did the same thing
you know a few days later
uh with different women uh with nothing
uh just sort of carrying nothing just
being you know regular and so
when he had the guitar case he got um
many more numbers many more phone
numbers
and i i'd wondered i've never seen any
research on this i don't know of any
even anecdotal stories but you know if
you're a musician uh you know have a you
know have some you know carrying a
guitar or some kind of instrument
uh i think that might be you know that
might be uh uh advantageous
probably depends on the instrument like
if you're carrying around a two bar i
don't know how that well that's gonna go
the uh a flute or uh yeah
clarinet yeah i mean maybe with the
clarinet i don't know probably not the
flute or the tuba
yeah yeah yeah i don't know
so what would be the most attractive
instruments do you think so i mean
probably yeah guitar but like how about
a piano like how would a piano look
saxophone might saxophone oh right yeah
there is yeah the sort of jazz and yeah
okay i can see that
um drums how would dru how do you think
women would see a guy with drums
oh i'd probably wondering why they were
carrying them all
well not not carrying but like by like
playing what i mean is like if you're on
the apps and you're sort of seeing that
or like on a website or something you
see a guy playing the drums i i think
like that might be you know i think
someone no i think that works i think
anything in in a band like that a guitar
a bass drums
anything like that would work didn't one
of the kardashians just and i could have
this wrong because i don't really follow
the kardashians but didn't
isn't one of them dating
oh this is a terrible story
that like rock guy who who plays the
drums hold on
okay
hold on i need to know this travis
barker doesn't he play the drums
i mean the name rings about
there we go i know i know things yeah
okay okay
kourtney kardashian dating travis barker
the drummer
so there you go there's an example all
right yeah yeah i think uh okay so so
the drop yeah drum yeah that'll be that
that could be added to the list you know
learn an instrument
um maybe yeah i'm thinking of others so
i those are sort of all of the
empirically based suggestions that i
have but i'm thinking of others like
maybe cooking you know if you're seeing
in the kitchen and you're cooking or
making some elaborate meal or something
and i think some of these like these
would actually be worth studying beyond
just
you know beyond the sort of usual like
the dog picture or something you know
more education but like actual hobbies
and activities which i think a lot of
guys already know right like i think
you'll see um pictures of guys who post
you know like outdoors pictures or
skydiving or i think all of those i mean
it's really interesting i hope that
there are some researchers out there who
are looking into this about like
you know what
what personality qualities is someone
conveying when they you know when they
have the the skydiving picture
i think um openness
yeah i think openness maybe extroversion
yeah um
probably low neuroticism or higher
emotions
oh i i bet it's that i bet it's that for
something like skydiving
yeah yeah you're sort of showing like
courage and the absence of anxiety
yeah i mean so i've gone skydiving and
bungee jumping actually and i didn't
find skydiving that that's scary i think
budgie jumping is much more terrifying
but i think most people associate
skydiving with more terror so maybe
that's like a better maybe that's a
better picture
how was the landing i wanted to go
skydiving but i have like a fake hip and
a fake ankle and i figured that if
something broke people would just be
like yeah maybe don't do that
all right well okay so so the first like
i don't know however many times you go
skydiving you you do like a tandem jump
so you're you're actually attached to
like a professional skydiving instructor
when you land when you land yeah so
you're attached the entire time and so
like they basically are like telling you
like you know when to put your feet up
like how to do it when to when to land
and so on i don't know if it would be
because i know that you have some you
know health conditions and stuff i don't
know if that would be worth uh risking
though that could be pretty tough i
i didn't have a problem with it but i
could imagine like if one little thing
goes wrong or like the wind blows at the
wrong time or something maybe it would
be but you'd have to talk to a
professional skydiving instructor to to
get the details they're just straight up
gonna say no though like this is like
not definitely not you oh well well you
you can go sky or you can go you can go
bungee jumping then you know put that on
put that on your uh you know your
webpage or whatever your your app page
because i think it looks cool like i
mean i have some pictures i this was
years ago so i went skydiving in 2009
before you know before all this you know
the dating app stuff had taken off but
you know i still managed to get some
cool pictures of jumping off the bridge
and stuff and i'm like you know that's
that's a cool picture
so yeah yeah
that's good that's good
um do you think
do you know any of the stats
about what's changed during covid for
dating apps like has dating app use gone
up because everyone's isolated or is
everyone
actually isolated and scared of dating
now
do you know anything about that you know
i i don't have any stats um about
about whether it dropped i mean my my
guess is at least for the first couple
of months of the pandemic probably there
was uh
a sort of reduced use
but then like just anecdotally just from
like talking to my friends a lot of my
friends who are single and especially my
friends who are younger and still in
college
uh it seemed like you know there was
like a a brief like eight week period of
oh let's you know be careful and then
they stopped and i mean i had a friend
who
so he he worked at a consultancy he was
right out of college in 2020 uh he went
on furlough which is basically
like you know they're paying him 20 to
not work anymore you know because they
were sort of reshuffling reorganizing
whatever and so they paid him 20 he took
a six month furlough and he said for six
months straight all he did was was go on
the apps and bring a different uh person
over to his house every day
uh to have a date and whatever else so
so he did this for six months straight
basically throughout the entire you know
lockdown uh and this was in the u.s and
yeah he was telling me it's funny he's
like i was so uh grossed out with myself
during that period
um but i was bored and had nothing else
to do because i couldn't go anywhere do
anything and all i had was the app so
that was my entertainment uh and uh yeah
he um
he ended up going on like this religious
retreat in israel
uh as a way to like like cleanse himself
of like all of his sids or all the stuff
that he had done he felt a little bit
repulsed about like just what he had and
so then he he was like i'm gonna turn
over a new leaf i'm deleting the apps
i'm never gonna do this again and then
he comes back from israel and he said
like within a week he downloaded all the
apps again he was doing the same thing
and all my other guy friends are telling
me the same stuff you know like i think
the people who actually had the best you
know the best time if you can call it
that
were people in relationships you know
like people who already had a party they
were just sort of chilling at home like
whatever watching netflix and hanging
out or whatever and like
the people who were um
you know trying to figure out the dating
apps like whether or not to put like i
think tinder had this special
like a special feature for people who
were vaccinated to like signal that
they're vaccinated and
you know there's like a bunch of
interesting ways that guys
interact with the apps i don't know if
you've heard of uh do you know about
woke fishing
okay let's get into woke i think i've
peripherally heard of woke fishing but
what is that well so you probably heard
about catfishing right catfishing like
pretending to be someone else on the
internet on social media or whatever but
woke fishing it was this thing um there
were a couple of articles about it uh i
think in vice and the new york post
basically uh
men pretending to be progressive to get
laid
uh and so they would put like you know
something of their tinder bio like you
know they'd put black lives matter or
you know climate change
reform now or something like that
and they would just sort of pretend to
do this but there were these stories of
like guys doing this you know putting
this and then they go on a date with a
girl and then later on
you know the women who are writing these
stories about this you know they'd go
home with a guy and find like books uh
by ann coulter on the bookshelf or like
a maga hat like stashed away in the
closet or something
or he likes this guy's joe rogan yeah
yeah yeah he has uh yeah yeah so he has
the you know jurgen app on his phone or
something or the spotify up with joe
rogan and so
i
yeah i think like yeah a lot of guys
were sort of like
trying to figure out how to how to you
know get the attention of women and get
their interest and
um
jeffrey miller the evolutionary
psychologist he's described this as
political peacocking
um
you know like
the animal the peacocks right like they
puff up their their feathers to get the
attention of the peahens
and he basically drew this analogy of
like guys you know broadcasting how they
care about you know xyz political issue
as a way to sort of you know demonstrate
their moral feathers of how good and how
noble and pure they are and
women might be
you know some some women might be
interested in in in guys like that so
yeah but those kind of guys are probably
not you know they're probably not very
honest well they're definitely not
honest but they may not be the kind of
guys you want to be around for very long
if they're willing to to lie about who
they are score high on the dark triad
probably right
huh that's interesting i wonder when
when some of these kind of ideologies
spread i wonder what percentage of
people
are like that right and then once it
gets popular they're like okay well this
is what makes me popular there's almost
it's almost like a
i gotta know an evolutionary mechanism
right if something takes over and you're
like okay well stay alive i've got to be
part of the crowd i'll just go along
with it i wonder what percentage of the
population an idea has to hit in order
for that to happen
it's definitely happened i would say now
with woke culture
yeah i mean
there's
there's some research showing that
if if 10
of the population comes to like hold an
idea very vehemently and very stridently
and they are inflexible in their
opinions they're unwilling to be moved
um then that idea does tend to
proliferate
simply because the rest of the 90 of the
culture
they either tend to have like even if
they have opposing opinions they may not
hold them very strongly
and basically if you have 10 percent of
the population who really believes in
their ideology
and 90 who
you know they believe it's a very they
believe what they believe to varying
degrees but generally they're more
flexible
then the smaller group will tend to uh
their ideas will tend to proliferate
right i mean it just makes sense if one
group's flexible the other group is
inflexible the inflexible group is going
to exert dominance over the the more
flexible group
um that's crazy 10
is not very high i would have assumed it
had to be higher than that i get the
inflexibility part but 10 is not very
many people
yeah yeah i mean it's i think this is um
uh i mean a good example of this would
be what you're describing here with you
know the woke culture and a lot of these
you know i've called some of some of
those ideas i've called them luxury
beliefs
uh which tend to be held by a very small
percentage of the population you know
tend to be you know disproportionately
educated and affluent and
you know most people don't agree with a
lot of this stuff i mean like the defund
the police and all this kind of stuff
like the vast majority of the population
thinks it's utterly insane
but you know the the rest of the
population um
you know they maybe don't have as much
influence or they don't spend as much
time interacting with politics or
whatever and so a lot of policies can
get pushed through that the majority of
the country doesn't necessarily agree
with
luxury beliefs has everybody
gotten you in trouble for that
nothing uh surprisingly little um
you know i haven't had any any issues
with it i've written about it multiple
times and
tweeted about it a lot i mean it's you
know it's funny like
when you're
in academia when you're phd student and
research and whatever like you come up
with all these ideas and you know some
of the ideas that you work really hard
on no one cares about and then like an
idea you spent 10 minutes on will
suddenly take off and that that was kind
of like that with luxury beliefs it's
just a term that popped into my head and
you know it's just uh the way i define
it is
ideas and opinions that confer status on
the upper class while inflicting costs
on the lower classes and so defund the
police is an obvious example but
i think there are some others as well um
and yeah it's uh
the whole like
inflexible
like small population exerting there
they're well over the others i think
like what i was seeing as an undergrad i
went to yale and here at cambridge i'm
seeing like very sort of affluent and
well-to-do people who hold
opinions that are way different from
ordinary people middle class people
working class people but
those are the ideas that get attention
and all of the sort of legacy media
outlets and stuff and
you know this is probably why they're
to some to some degree uh at least one
reason why they're so upset with um you
know podcasters and people who are more
independent and people who have
interesting guests on people like you
people like rogan and so on is that like
you know they only want their people to
to get attention and
audiences
what's it like being at cambridge if
you're not like is it how's cambridge
doing in regards to being woke or not
it's it's not as bad as like some of the
you know
top universities in the us
but it's still like pretty bad you know
your dad was disinvited from here a
couple years ago uh which infuriated me
um
because i was really looking forward to
having him here i mean part of the
reason why i applied to cambridge was
because um of his influence you know why
i applied to grad school uh was because
of of watching uh some of your dad's
work in some of his videos and so
you know there is like an activist
contingent here but um
you know it's lately it seems to have
cooled down somewhat um you know your
you and your dad your dad were here
pretty recently and there wasn't too
much too much of that stuff going on
but
you know i i try to keep my head down
i've had like private conversations
actually with professors here who've
said like you know i'm surprised you
haven't had more
you know like more people haven't tried
to come after you or something and i'm
like like it's weird because on the one
hand i feel like i haven't said anything
that badly or anything got wrong like
whatever i i have like pretty moderate
opinions i think
um but on the other hand i sort of get
what they're saying because you know
being a moderate in certain environments
like you're
you're perceived as you know uh a you
know crazy extremist or something
okay there's um
so one of the articles it's kind of what
we've been talking about i want to read
one thing
maybe more than one thing oh but it's
um
people being afraid to talk nowadays
so this was this was scary and i didn't
know this at all
but you wrote results from a recent
paper titled keeping your mouth shut
spiraling self-censorship in the u.s
says they find that self-censorship has
skyrocketed in the 1950s at the height
of mccarthyism
13.4 percent of americans reported that
they felt less free to speak their mind
than they used to in 1987 the figure had
reached 20 percent by 2019 40 of
americans reported that they did not
feel free to speak their minds
and then this isn't a partisan issue
either
the percentage of democrats who are
worried about speaking their mind is
just about identical to the percentage
of republicans who self-censor 39 and 40
respectively
that's
insane 40
of people
are worried about it compared to
mccarthyism too
yeah
yeah it's uh yeah right so in the 1950s
during mccarthyism it was 13 of
americans said they don't feel free to
speak what's on their minds and
you know the most recent uh survey like
you said is around 40 regardless of
political party which i find interesting
um
i can see that going sort of you know
like why there's where
the political difference is interesting
i think part of it is just um among if
you're a democrat right like i think a
lot of people believe that you know uh
maybe for democrat you should have a
little bit more flexibility or freedom
because you tend to agree with whatever
the prevailing ideology is or something
at least in the sort of sociocultural
context
and
you know i think a lot of them like i
have close friends who are who are
democrats that they're actually like
kind of uh
you know they walk on eggshells they're
careful with what they say
um i think a lot of this stuff you know
i've i've written at length about how
much of the the the cultural trends and
the fashions we're seeing it's i mean
it's a little bit political sure but i
think it's much more about class
i was raised you know i grew up in a
working-class town in california
by you know i was raised by democrats
who didn't go to college who were more
working class and who
when i visit them now it's like you know
they they're still centrist democrats
you know when i grew up they were
john kerry supporters in 2004 but they
you know they're they're just so
disconnected from a lot of the the
cultural stuff that
more educated people talk about like you
know it really is a sort of class-based
thing
um you know they'll
they'll casually make like sweeping
stereotypical remarks about gender
and they speak in a way that would
actually uh make college-educated
republicans uncomfortable right about
like oh yeah
that's interesting i wonder what
percentage of the population just isn't
paying attention to this
i think it's like a democrat
oh that's scary yeah yeah i think
there's a lot of that because most
people i mean most people don't
subscribe to any news media outlet they
don't really consume or keep up with a
lot of this stuff
um it is very much
a sort of upper-class upper-middle and
upper-class thing right if you go to
college and
you know you're supposed to supposed to
you know stay informed or whatever i
mean
it's yeah when i when i first entered
university i was just shocked at how
important
people seemed to believe it was to like
read the latest op-eds and articles and
all this sort of
updates on vocabulary and all these
trends and stuff that was so totally
checked out from before
um but the the self-censorship thing
something else that was interesting
about that um i don't remember if i put
in that article or not i've written
about it elsewhere is that
it's um
it it's it's correlated with education
such that uh and this is this is perhaps
linked to you know people who are
democrats but they just don't know
what's going on right is that um
there's they're sort of not keeping up
with the trends or something as much as
educated people um so non-college
educated people
uh it was something like only if i'm
recalling the numbers correctly they may
be a little off but they're
basically around 20
of
high school graduates so people who
highest level of education they were in
college around 20 say they self-censored
and then it was like you know something
like 30 percent or 35 of college grads
and then for postgraduates it was like
more than half something crazy like that
so basically the more educated you are
the more likely you are to self-censor
um and i think is that
okay sorry is that partly because i know
that there's a correlation between
maybe this maybe there's not a
correlation but people say that the
smarter you are the more you know what
you don't know
do you think it has anything to do with
that or is it being educated in an
ideological fashion
well that's interesting i could imagine
it
perhaps being the result of both of
those things but but again like the more
you know what you don't know
uh you know that indicates that you're
sort of um
intellectually humble that you're you
know sort of open-minded or something
but this specific question is about you
know do you not speak what's on your
mind so this is actually you know these
are thoughts and opinions that you
already hold are you willing to express
them
and it seems that the more education you
have the less willing you are to to
express yourself um it actually seems to
indicate that the more educated you are
the less open-minded you think the
people around you are
uh and so maybe it actually is at odds
with this notion that the more educated
you are the more you know you don't you
know you don't know what you know or you
know what you don't know or something
like that um and so
yeah i think this is fascinating too
that actually the most educated people
you know it's almost at the reverse of
what you would expect and i think the
researchers in that paper right sided
they say something like there is this um
there is this gradual sort of cultural
awareness that like as you obtain more
education and sort of verizon
socioeconomic status you sort of learn
that uh you're supposed to keep your
mouth shut in certain instances and
you're not allowed to say certain things
you have to be careful and walk on
eggshells and
um
yeah it's it's just uh that part of the
reason why i wrote that entire article
was because of how shocking i found that
because i had grown up thinking it was
the reverse that the more education and
earning power and just sort of the
higher socioeconomic status the more
freedom you'll have
but at least in this sort of social
context it's actually the reverse it's
the less freedom you have um or at least
the less freedom you feel to to speak
what's on your mind
hmm
wow well i bet there are a number of
reasons for that
that's yeah
that's strange
interesting okay what got you interested
in all of these different topics
uh yeah i mean i've always been a pretty
curious person
uh but you know again i
i came from quite a bit of a different
social background than a lot of um a lot
of the you know people that i went to
college with so
i actually grew up in foster homes in
los angeles
and then i was adopted later
into a working-class family in northern
california
how old were you when that happened
i was seven i was almost eight uh when i
was adopted so my
my biological mother came to california
from the u.s or came to california from
from south korea sorry
uh when when she was a woman and when i
was three she became addicted to drugs
and
so yeah i never knew who my father was
and so i spent the next five years or so
in foster homes around la and
um
yeah and then
moved to northern california and yeah it
was just sort of economically
uh and and socially too sort of in terms
of my family structure i mean just very
uh challenging for me as a kid growing
up um
it's actually a really bad student you
know just totally checked out just
because my home life was such a mess
and
so you know i joined the military right
out of high school when i was 17
wow
i know nothing about you
yeah yeah we talked a little bit when
you were when you were here but you know
we were i think we were both very busy
and there was a lot going on
but yeah um
yeah i was in the military and did an
enlistment served mostly i was actually
overseas for most of it i was in germany
did a couple of deployments uh to the
middle east and
it was from there that i went to college
as a slightly older you know like a
mature student
um and so i think all of those
experiences together
combined with my probably innate
curiosity
led me to be interested in you know
why people are the way they are why are
there these like odd class differences
and how people carry themselves and
their opinions and their beliefs and
you know like what's going on with with
the dating scene and all of these things
have been you know it's just been all
super interesting to me
um
are you going to write a book what are
your plans
yeah i'm writing a memoir actually
about my sort of experiences in foster
care and what life was like growing up
in
you know my dusty uh working class town
in the late 90s and early 2000s and
you know how i came to
to uh end up in in these sort of fancy
universities and and what i've learned
and all those kinds of things
so yeah that's my my project now um is
is the memoir when is that when do you
think you're gonna wrap that up when is
it gonna be published i know there's big
delays now for printing so
yeah
yeah i mean i'm still well so i have the
manuscript done i'm working on revisions
right now with
my editors at simon schuster
um sort of going back and forth on
certain things and you know trying to
you know whatever so so um
probably late this year i'm thinking uh
so i'm that's my goal is to have it on
track because i'll be finishing up my
phd program here cambridge
uh probably like late summer early fall
somewhere around there and then if the
book came out um you know right around
that time or a little bit after i think
that would be ideal
you know if i wanted to go on a book
tour or or to um to deliver talks or
whatever to to sort of promote the book
and and share um all the stuff that i've
learned
okay that's very cool
that's very cool did you have me back on
to talk about it oh i will for sure
for sure
yes please um did you have
trouble like i assume writing about
foster care and some of these
experiences is
like heavy right and i know um i've been
trying to
write about
some of the stuff that i went through
and i i find that when i wrote it down i
wrote too much almost like the stuff
that was heavier there was like too much
detail yeah so did did you have any
issues writing out
hard topics
are you reading a memoir mikayla yeah
okay cool yeah yeah yeah i'm looking
forward to reading that too um
and
yeah so i've never actually talked about
uh yeah the writing experience on a
podcast before so this is kind of cool i
mean
it was
it was hard i mean i've written i had
written about
uh a lot of this stuff
even before the book so the way i even
landed this book deal was i wrote an
op-ed in the new york times in 2018
uh it was like a 900-word summary of my
life basically
it was titled um why being a foster
child made me a conservative um
and
i can see that being popular
it was it was popular it was a little
bit controversial they're not as
controversial as i'd expected
um but then like that was the thing that
got the attention of you know literary
agents and publishers and stuff
um so i had some experience writing
about my life before but like getting
into like the granular details of it uh
it was it was hard i mean
it was actually um
it was hard
enough to the point where if i had known
how hard it was gonna be i wouldn't have
done it
uh just because like uh the uh emotional
exhaustion
and the time and the
like reenacting all of it because i
tried to write each chapter from the
perspective of myself at that age so if
i'm seven years old in a foster home i
tried to remember what was it actually
like there what do i remember
you know who was around you know what
was school like all those things
and it was really it was really
exhausting i don't know if that was even
the best way to do it but that's the way
i chose to do it um and i ended up
writing more than i needed as well i
mean i think the contract called for
like 80 to 90 000 words and i ended up
writing more than 100 000. um
but you know in my case i mean yeah i
mean you probably are aware of a lot of
this too but i i sent it to
um a bunch of different uh people
writers and people that i respect and
ask them for feedback and ask them to be
i asked them all actually the same set
of questions
um
you know like what did you like about
the book what did you do it's like you
know what was your favorite part what
was you know your least favorite or less
you know less engaging part and so on
and you know i was trying to get um
you know uh
psychologists sometimes call when they
do their research inter-rater
reliability uh which is like do all
people agree on something essentially
and uh if you know
out of those 10 people if a handful of
them or some number of them said like
this part was a little boring or dull or
i didn't get it or whatever i either
changed it or or removed it and after
you know going through that process a
couple times um yeah i whittled it down
to get it within that word count
um you know i try to keep in mind uh
you know this
idea that um you know i've read this
from multiple different authors actually
that the the worst thing a book can be
is boring
uh and so you know if any part of the
the feedback i got was like oh this was
a little bit slow or something i'm like
all right i got to change it or remove
it
yeah
interesting did you find that more of
the i mean we can get into this more too
when we actually talk about when i
actually read your book when you come
back on but did you find that some of
the harder things you wrote about you
had better memory of
huh
yeah yeah you know i
i some of them yeah
um
some of them i did have a better memory
of some of them i mean i have
i think the bittersweet memories were
the ones that i had the easiest time
recalling and writing those are the ones
that have stayed with me
but there were some really intense
negative memories as well
you know i write about for example
when i was first adopted
i was adopted by a married couple a man
and a woman and their young daughter who
was their you know biological daughter
who became my adoptive younger sister
um who's uh younger than me three years
younger and so
i remember like when i moved in with
them and how happy i was to like you
know say the words mom and dad and like
oh like i have a mom and i have a dad
now and i don't have to you know
and my sister i remember like
it it you know
somehow i
it once it had i had internalized the
fact that um because all of the foster
homes i had lived in either i was always
moving or my foster siblings were always
being taken
right like i would make a bond with one
of my foster siblings and then they'd go
back to their parents or they go to
another home and so i was never sure who
would be leaving and when
but when i realized that um my sister
and i neither of us were ever going to
be taken from each other
um
you know like i distinctly remember that
feeling and writing about it and then
also
when she gave me some toys because all
the foster rooms i've lived and i never
had any toys and so when my sister gave
me some toys like you know like it was
first it was confusing to me because i
had never had that experience before
of a kid giving or anyone giving me toys
but the fact that this little younger
than me this little kid is giving me
toys is like
confusing but also like you know it sort
of cemented our bond together
and so like those those kinds of
memories
you know it's it was at the time happy
but in hindsight it's actually kind of
sad those were the kind of memories that
i remember the most
wow
this is going to be a crazy book this
should do well yeah
um part of
have you felt better since kind of
finishing the manuscript does it feel
like
that like resolved anything or you got
some of this emotional i don't know
trauma out
yeah i mean well i hated the process of
writing it actually yeah yeah you know
like
are you how far along are you
so i i have a hundred and seventy
thousand words and i haven't covered the
last two years
in the last two years
were awful last three three years so any
i need to get rid of like i'm sure it's
all just like
there's too much going on there so i
need to cut like half of it
that's a that's a it's a sturdy
uh memoir
yeah that's uh you know that's a thick
one 170 000 words bad
um
but but you know like it's i i mean like
how long have you been been at the
process
since so because dad always taught me to
write out you know traumatizing memories
right
so i i actually started writing after i
had my hip and ankle replaced when i was
18 so i had that done when i was 17. so
i started writing through these when i
was 18. so i've been doing this
since i was 18. i really
focused on making into a book when i was
23 but then things got so weird that i
was like well i can't end it here i feel
like i can end it now though but so i've
been doing this
for years and it's been yeah pretty
grueling the last part is really
grueling
yeah i can i mean yeah that's
yeah i mean just from what little i i
know and i've heard i mean i can
imagine i mean it's yeah but at least it
sounds like you had some of it already
sort of prepared and yeah so it wasn't
like yeah like the stuff from when i was
a kid too like that i'd gone through so
many times that it was
easier
right
yeah yeah for me it was i mean i had
like notes and and um
you know just like scraps and ideas and
stuff that i've accumulated over the
last few years
but it wasn't it was like literally i
had to like write you know 90 000 words
in 18 months or something and so i had
like targets to set for myself
of you know
whatever 300 words today or x number of
words tomorrow and you know if i can get
this many words by this date then then
it's fine
um
but then like you know once it was once
the like
first draft was done i i did feel a lot
better and i'm like wow i can't believe
it's i can't believe it's over and like
the fact like i mean when i was able to
end it in a way that i liked and that
was satisfying you know because
memoirs are weird right because it's
like your life is still going there's no
like real end yeah but how do you make a
satisfying conclusion to all of the
themes that you've discussed
and and
make it satisfying for the reader too
not just for yourself and um
once i got there i think i was like
finally and i'm like i'm so done with
this thing and i'm actually not done
because i'm still going through edits
and revisions but at least the sort of
the the marble block is there like chip
away at it but yeah it's uh
you know it's a weird process um
and i'm kind of glad i'm you know i'm
doing it and i'm glad i'm done but you
know it's uh it's not something i i
would have agreed to had i known what it
was going to be like
um i don't know how you feel i mean it
sounds like you're
you're having a different experience
with with yours
yeah well i kept a diary since i was in
grade one so i had
i just had so many details that i don't
think i would have remembered otherwise
so it's difficult for me to say like
this really doesn't matter like part of
these things just don't matter so i'm at
the point where i need people to go
through it and think and go whoa like
there's way too much detail there or
like no one cares about this
yeah yeah i i talked to my my sister so
i mentioned my adoptive sister asking
her what she remembers i talked to like
you know friends from high school i
haven't talked to i mean now it's been
you know 13 plus years since i've talked
to some of my friends from high school
and asking them like you know do you
remember that like trying to get the
memories right or at least as right as
possible but it's really weird like
writing
um
memories
because you know so for example i talked
to my my mom my adoptive mom about a
conversation we'd had when i was nine
uh and i told her like oh do you
remember the time we were in a car
outside of this house and you told me
about xyz
and i did this and like you know
whatever and i'm describing this to her
and she was like we weren't in a car
like we were at a different house on
someone else's porch it wasn't nighttime
it was like early morning like you know
just like the the basic detail like the
basic part of it is right but all the
details i got
one of us got wrong or maybe we're both
wrong right and that part is hard for me
to like reconcile that like okay so we
have different recollection of when that
conversation took place and what was
going on around us
um
and so like you know like every other
memoir you always have to put like you
know these are these are true at least
as i remember it but of course like no
one can truly verify some of these
things you know
cool yeah okay well i'm looking forward
to when that comes out definitely send
me a copy we'll talk about it when's the
when's yours coming
well i wasn't willing to finish it until
there was a good ending like you said
it's weird because it's your life um and
my dad was so sick for so long that i
was just like i can't like
it's just this like depressing you know
autoimmune chronically ill child and
then i get better and then her dad gets
sick and and then it ends i was like
that's not gonna work it was like i'll
just wait until dad gets better assuming
that's gonna happen and he's better now
and things are like
it seems more conclusive so
i've just been so swamped with
everything else it's hard to like
i've got a book deal but it's hard for
me to
there's not enough pressure and so i
haven't been like pri you know i've got
like my dad's brand and then i have the
podcast thing so i haven't been like
just half an hour a day right i haven't
got to that plus i think i needed to
process something so probably almost
ready for another
sprint
yeah yeah i mean
it was surprising yeah like like the
processing of it and sort of like mining
through all of those emotions and stuff
like yeah i don't think of myself as a
particularly
you know like oh so like i took your
your dad's personality test and i scored
in like i don't know like the bottom
10th percentile on uh neuroticism or you
know just like really like yeah i'm just
not that that emotional but that process
was like surprisingly uh you know
brought up a lot of feelings and stuff
and yeah it's uh it's a it's a crazy
experience just you know trying to
relive your life in the span of a couple
of years again you know
so
yeah
that's wild
yeah okay rob
if p if people want to find you online
where should they go
uh you can go to my website uh rob k
henderson.com or follow me on twitter at
rob k henderson
okay we'll link all those below too
sounds good thank you thank you very
much for coming on we'll have you back
for your book that'll be fun maybe make
specific i don't know it'll be
yeah yeah it'll be it'll be an
interesting discussion and thanks
[Music]
you